mein team hat das sich ihnen heute
mitbringen
24 monate nun wir von angst von panik
von hysterie und lockt downs von masken
pflicht von grünen bässen und
abstandsregeln gequält unsere grund und
freiheitsrechte fuhren eingeschränkt
eine litanei von gerichtsverfahren und
urteilen auch in deutschland aber auch
vor dem verfassungsgerichtshof in
österreich zeigen dass die verfassung
gebrochen wurde unter der abstrakten
gefahr eines virus war es möglich
freiheitsrechte einzuschränken
wir haben kollektiven selbstmord
begangen aus angst vor den coronado
24 monate später ist ja wir müssen den
satz formulieren die pandemie ist zu
ende omega und zeigt uns dass die
gefährlichkeit des virus abgenommen hat
ein zehntel dem der grippe nunmehr ist
israel beerdigt seine maßnahmen den
grünen bass die niederlande dänemark
großbritannien die schweiz schweden nur
österreich und deutschland beharrt auf
diesem weg der angst und panik in
deutschland stellt deutschlands
gesundheitsminister lauterbach in
aussicht dass die pandemie in zehn
jahren noch nicht zu ende sein wird ich
prophezeie die pandemie ist zu ende
genauso wie die junge amtszeit des
deutschen gesundheitsministers karl
lauterbach
an der stelle stellt sich natürlich für
den otto normalverbraucher oder für mich
die frage was glauben sie denn warum
herr lauterbach mit dieser prognose der
nächsten zehn jahre überhaupt erst
das überhaupt aus suggeriert oder das
öffentlich macht glauben sie wirklich
dass er diese angst panik hat was die
gesundheit in der beratung gruppen
angeht oder glauben sie dass das
politische hintergründe hat oder
vielleicht andere vorteile ich glaube es
ist ein gemisch aus geistiger
beschäftigungslosigkeit und aus einer
angst und panikstörungen die lauterbach
offenbar für sich inhaliert hat wie es
trösten ja auch nicht anders sieht ich
erinnere an trost der 2006 mit der
schweinegrippe den gleichen ziel oper
aufführen wollte wie es nun mussten dann
mit merkel und sparen geschafft hat und
lauterbach nun vollzieht es ist eine
mischung aus angst und panik es ist eine
mischung aus wichtigtuerei
und das ist eine mischung aus einem
ungleichgewicht wir geben den biologen
und medizinern die gesamte politische
macht obwohl die politik die an auf die
aufgabe hätte zu gewichten die
psychische gesundheit der menschen die
physische gesundheit der menschen die
wirtschaftliche gesundheit des staates
die soziale gesundheit unseres gesamten
gefüge wenn es nämlich so einfach wäre
dann räumen wir in berlin die charité
aus ersetzen sie auf der regierungsbank
die nächsten vier jahre und schmeißen
unsere politiker auf den misthaufen so
einfach ist es eben nicht denn der
bundestag besteht aus volksvertretern
und daher appelliere ich an die
volksvertreter in österreich und in
deutschland vielleicht nach 24 monaten
so etwas wie vernunft wieder walten zu
lassen frau sei aber wir wurden in die
cola maßnahmen oder auch karl lauterbach
innerhalb des öffentlich rechtlichen
rundfunks wahrgenommen ich habe ja
gesagt ich muss ja bestimmt ich habe als
bürgerin kritische kommentare vermisst
wobei das zdf noch besser war als a d
das muss ich wirklich sagen als zdf war
dann doch noch etwas mutiger finde ich
also ich kann wirklich nicht für das
gesamte zdf er sein programm sprechen
ich kann nur persönlich sagen dass wir
vor allem ein problem mit der
diskriminierung haben und dass dieser
grundsatz der diskriminierungsfreiheit
ist im zdf staatsvertrag verankert
genauso wie er auch in der ard im
rundfunkstaatsvertrag verankert ist
dieses prinzip haben wir auf
verschiedensten arten und weisen im
programm nicht mehr gegeben also sprich
wir hören eine indien kämen die jetzt
sehr beliebte moderatorin für die
wissenschaftssendungen auch gerade für
die jüngere zielgruppe die dann einen
ein video in social media eröffnet mit
dem satz also alle ungeimpften können es
gleich mal abschalten da ist für mich
der grundsatz der
diskriminierungsfreiheit nicht mehr
gewährleistet und das ist das was mich
bei herrn lauterbach besonders
beschäftigt dass er das von anfang an
bis jetzt durchgezogen hat und sich
dafür überhaupt nicht geniert und dass
das wirklich wie sie schon richtig
gesagt haben gegen unsere eigentlich
unser grundgesetz verstößt ich beziehe
mich natürlich jetzt da immer auf den
staatsvertrag weil mich das auch
interessiert wie sich das zdf da verhält
und das hätte er fährt aber da natürlich
auch ein problem weil zum beispiel jetzt
letzten juni amtlich wurde gerichtlich
eine frontal21 reporterin hat es quasi
gerichtlich bewiesen dass das zdf seine
frauen schlechter bezahlt als männer da
es auch das nominierung im spiel ganz
klar das ist also jetzt amtlich und
trotzdem ist es immer noch 1 bewiesen
dass beim zdf die weiblichen reporter
schlechter bezahlt sie männlich nicht
nur die reporter sondern überhaupt die
mitarbeiter also es gibt ja dieses jahr
2017 dieses gesetz nachdem man sich
erkundigen darf ob die männlichen
kollegen mit vergleichbarer tätigkeit
gleich viel oder mehr verdienen als frau
diese reporterin war aber nur im dritten
kreis umher reichen die
schlechtmöglichste
einstellungs stufe also eigentlich
scheinselbstständigkeit da hat man
dieses recht nicht das muss man sich
erst auch erst mal reinziehen man das
mit der steuerkarte beim zdf hat aber
kein informationsrecht dieses auskunft
recht hat sie sich erst mal erstritten
um dann zu erfahren wie gesagt das ging
dann bis zum bundesarbeitsgericht dass
es also system hat und seit der f dass
die frauen schlechter verdienen als die
männer daran hat sich bis heute nichts
geändert würde jetzt gerne hier einfach
das exempel statuieren um zollfragen
aber leider ist paul einige hierarchie
stufen über wir uns solche deswegen auch
hoffentlich mehr verdienen aber deswegen
die frage ein dichter musca lauterbach
weg
nein karl lauterbach muss nicht weg ich
finde das spannend das gerät muss sich
in den kreis derjenigen ein reiz weil
danach die erst gesagt haben herr
lauterbach würde auf gar keinen fall
gesundheitsminister dann in den
koalitionsverhandlungen noch einmal
gesagt haben dann ein das heißt schon
entschlossen herr lauterbach wird auf
gar keinen fall gesundheitsminister und
jetzt anfangen zu sagen hallo was
amtszeit ja die ist eigentlich schon
fast vorbei ich glaube da muss man
manifestieren dass die große mehrheit
der deutschen
seltsamerweise es gar nicht so schlecht
findet wenn jemand immer noch warnt und
warnt und immer noch darauf hinweist wie
vielleicht doch gefährlich oder auch
nicht vor oder ist das lässt allerdings
nach von daher wird es spannend zu sehen
sein wie sich vor lauter wasser
entwickelt ich muss sagen ich finde ihn
als politischer politikertypus irgendwie
sympathisch ich weiß da stehe ich
vielleicht relativ verhalten mit meiner
meinung bei bild aber ich mag ihn wie er
auftritt er lässt sich anbrüllen
anschreit am nächsten tag wieder in die
sendung lena du hast
ja auch
ich habe erlebt wie wolfgang kubicki
damals ja berichtet hat wieder in seiner
kneipe über ihn gesprochen wird und ihn
als dumpfbacken und spacken bezeichnet
also so hat die kneipe angeblich über
ihn gesprochen und die beiden haben sich
dann auch wieder vertragen also als als
rheinische auch so ein bisschen
frohnatur wenn auch eher professor natur
mag ich ihn irgendwie unabhängig davon
muss er sich ja auch politisch beweisen
jetzt komm ich jetzt sozusagen zum ernst
zurück tatsächlich ist es so dass er das
corona thema irgendwann wegfällt und
dann geht es um die großen themen die
viele menschen in deutschland bewegen
zum beispiel die frage was in der pflege
passiert was ist mit unseren
gesundheitsbeiträge und bei all diesen
themen wird er sich beweisen müssen dass
sein ministerium möglich führen kann das
hat er finde ich bislang noch nicht
bewiesen und das wird dann ab musste
aber man muss sich doch solange sorgen
machen so lang an oder machen in dieser
häufigkeit überhaupt twitter-meldungen
absetzung überhaupt öffentlich ist also
so ist er ja überhaupt minister geworden
das finde ich medial wiederum eine
spannende frage wie wird man heute
eigentlich minister es handelt sich ja
nicht unbedingt um eine kompetenzprüfung
die man durchlaufen muss sondern die
häufigkeit der thematisierung in den
medien und vor allem wenn es nur darum
geht dass mein tv shows auftritt wie
gesagt man kann sogar bundespräsident
werden also ich hoffe mit blick auf karl
lauterbach dann noch hoffnung aber er
uns heime falsch es ist keine prognose
dass er da kürzt die für systemen
gesundheitsminister wird es ist ein
heimlicher wunsch von mir denn in
österreich und deutschland sind
mittlerweile das letzte übrig gebliebene
versuchslabor der sogenannten corona
maßnahmen der autokratischen maßnahmen
wir sind übrig geblieben alle länder in
europa haben die pandemie für beendet
erklärt nur in österreich oder in
deutschland verspürt man uns auch eine
sadomasochistische lust sich zu knechten
oder sich knechten zu lassen oder die
knechtschaft sich ausrichten zu lassen
also jetzt karl lauterbach der lustige
typ ist weil er uns erklärt dass unsere
freiheit die nächsten 20 jahre zehn
jahre per du ist sprich flöten geht dann
ist man vielleicht in einem gestrengen
keller besser aufgehoben würde ich mal
sagen also ich gehöre nicht zu denen ich
bin ein sehr freiheitsliebender ein sehr
liberaler mensch und ich will meine alte
normalität und meine freiheit wieder
zurück nicht die freiheit die kleinen
die sie uns gegeben sondern die freiheit
und um tickets